on Monday Texas senator Ted Cruz and his  wife were driven out of a DC restaurant  by protesters who were angry with him  over his handling of the Brett Kavanaugh  hearing this this is real footage take a  look that's just uh just an incredible  strange time were in I mean that's a  weird scene can you imagine that Andy I  don't have to imagine it it happened to  me the other day it's happened to you  what do you what do you mean it happen  to you I'm telling you one minute I'm  eating my dinner and the next minute I'm  being hounded out by a bunch of  strangers I mean somebody actually just  posted it on the web  [Applause]  [Music]  you were at a funeral a lot of those  things have buffets that guy was popular  did you eat Lourdes did you know the guy  I mean I got to know  [Laughter]  you